Pennsylvania judge handed out the first
jail sentences in the hazing death of
Penn State sophomore Timothy Piazza the
19 year old died in February of 2017
after an alcohol fueled event at the
Beta Theta Pi fraternity house Piazza's
death led to criminal charges against 28
former fraternity members three of them
will now serve time behind bars
Jericka Duncan is here with the details
of their punishment
Jericka good morning good morning we've
been covering this story from the very
very beginning this has been one of the
largest hazing prosecutions in US
history the three former Beta Theta Pi
brothers who received jail time
yesterday had pleaded guilty to charges
related to hazing 21-year old Luke
Visser and Michael Bonaduce were both
sentenced to up to six months in jail 20
year-old Joshua Carducci received up to
nine months the judge also gave 21
year-old Joseph Saleh up to 10 months of
house arrest all four men also received
probation and will pay fines this urbana
Tucci and Saleh were given community
service the judge may later amend the
three sentences to house arrest
Piazza family attorney Tom Klein said
Timothy's parents Jim and Evelyn were in
the courtroom for yesterday's sentencing
Klein said it was a significant step
forward in the long road to justice
meanwhile there are still more members
to be sentenced last year a judge
dismissed the most serious allegations
against some of the students including
felony aggravated assault charges
a judge also tossed involuntary
manslaughter charges against the
fraternities president and pledge master
who are still awaiting trial and I can
tell you speaking with those parents
when all of this first happened they
were determined to see this thing
through and also not just because they
wanted justice and reference to the
people they believed were involved but
they also want to make sure that message
of how dangerous hazing is gets out
there they want to prevent standing on
their feet every time I see that picture
of Piazza in the football jersey or with
this baseball cap turned on backwards
again and we've all talked to his
parents and you feel their pain and they
really do want to help others but they
also want justice for their son I hope
this gives them some amount of comfort
because nothing will bring him back we
know that
Tajima Neverland I think of them all the
time I do - nor I think of them and they
are doing is so admirable letting it be
known that there will be punishment for
this kind of behavior they are trying to
will form this fraternity system
absolutely thank you drink a you've been
on this room there they were in court
again yesterday imagine that nor you
have to sit listen to this again